in the previous lessons we discussed how
one can perform differentially expressed
Gene analysis at the end of a standard
rna-seq pipeline in this video we will
learn how you can perform
differentiating expression analysis
separately
note that in this demo pipeline we are
making use of the gene expression table
that was generated as an output from the
rnac pipeline the motto of this pipeline
is to find out differentially expressed
genes and further annotate the Pathways
in which they are involved so let's
start by building the pipeline
this is followed by the D sector for
differential gene expression analysis of
rna-seq data
besides identifying the significant
genes we can also determine the
biological implication of these
significant genes using the enrichment
analysis and GSA algorithm
and note that the description of each of
the algorithms have been explained in
the pop-ups that show when you click on
each of the steps so feel free to browse
through and learn at your pace
click on N to finish the pipeline
and with that in our next video we will
discuss what are the various outputs and
how to interpret them